tragedia en el sur de Ecuador tras las
intensas lluvias en la localidad de
arausí un deslizamiento de tierra se
saldó con la vida de varias a personas
dejando algunas casas cubiertas de lodo
y otras totalmente destruidas
un tremendo sonido dije ya se desploma
el cerro El Fuerte temporal deja al
menos 500 damnificados y varios
desaparecidos que ahora los equipos de
rescate y los voluntarios se esfuerzan
por encontrar estamos parado aquí sobre
20 metros de material pétreo que cubre
un estadio aquí abajo entre la
desolación de los vecinos en la conocida
como nariz del por su pronunciada
pendiente El Ejecutivo de lasso prometió
actuar para ayudar a Los afectados el
gobierno está totalmente activo enfocado
en la tragedia de alausí tanto la
dirección de riesgos cuerpo de bomberos
fuerzas armadas policía nacional la Cruz
Roja el Ministerio de salud pública y el
Ministerio de bienestar social más allá
de alausí las Fuertes lluvias han
destruido carreteras puentes y otras
infraestructuras en todo el país solo en
lo que va de año se han reportado 987
incidentes peligrosos relacionados con
las precipitaciones por lo que el
gobierno declaró estado de emergencia en
14 provincias